Lara is in Memphis hey Lara how are you
- good how are you better than I deserve
what's up my husband and I are debt free
besides our house we are living in a
different city temporarily owner lay
down our car we blew an engine so we're
faced with the decision of we put
potentially could be moving in a couple
of months looking to maybe buy a new
different car just trying to make a
decision of every should fix the car or
if we should buy a new one is the car
worth if the engine was working like
seven grand
okay and the engine you literally blew
the engine you dropped a rod I mean it's
I mean I have to they told me I needed a
brand new engine yeah okay all right
well you don't put a brand new engine in
a $7,000 car you put a junkyard engine a
used engine in a $7,000 car okay and
that's going to cost 25% of what a new
one would go I mean you could spend
$7,000 on a new engine and you would
never yeah yeah you'd never do that so
that doesn't make any sense at all but
you might put a thousand dollar car
engine in it or something like that and
$500 for the labor kind of a shade tree
situation or something and you know get
the thing running again and get it sold
you might do that or you sell it salvage
like it is but it's gonna I mean if it's
7,000 with an engine blown it's probably
not gonna bring - exactly
and so um but yeah you don't put a new
one in it if you fix it at all you put a
used engine in it and then you plan on
driving it or selling it with that used
engine in it disclosing to the buyer
that it has a second engine in it well
that's not that big a deal in a $7,000
car it's not what kind of car is it it's
a Ford Fusion we we've gotten a lot of
use out of my husband drives first job
so he drives like 50,000 miles a year so
we haven't had it that long
but they just go fast and you drive that
much yeah the game money is saying
yeah we have a fully fun an emergency
fund so you're about to buy a car I
think okay III wouldn't screw with it I
would sell it for Salvage and put some
money with it and go buy me a car okay
all right does that make sense to you no
okay
thanks for the call